four days ago we marked the 10th
anniversary of September 11 and those of
you who happen to read the weekend
interview in last Saturday's Wall Street
Journal know that when news of the
attacks that day broke our luncheon
speaker today was at a doctor's office
under the protection of a security
detail hearing news of the attack he
asked the US Marshal attached to him is
this our guys by which he meant al-qaeda
our speaker was well aware of al Qaeda
even then because six years earlier he
presided over the trial of the al Qaeda
terrorists who attacked the World Trade
Center in 1993 Michael Mukasey graduated
from Columbia University in 1963 and
received his JD from Yale Law School in
1967 from 19 72 to 76 he served as
assistant US attorney for the Southern
District of New York in 1987 President
Reagan appointed him to serve as a judge
on the you in the US District Court that
same district and he remained on that
court until two thousand six in 2007
President George W Bush nominated him to
become the 81st US Attorney General and
the confirmation process in the Senate
eventually successful was quite
contentious for reasons relevant to the
topic he will speak on here today that
topic is national security in the
Constitution in the Obama administration
please join me in welcoming former US
Attorney General Michael Mukasey
thank you very much for that kind i
should say lavish introduction and also
the Hillsdale College for marking
constitution day that is the anniversary
of the date when the constitution was
ratified with the celebration of the
sort that I think those who labored over
that constitution would have been
pleased with that actually involves a
serious discussion of what the document
says and means and of course I'm
flattered to be included in such an
event my assigned topic today is is
national security and the Constitution
in the Obama administration or so I was
told and I will also take it as a given
that considering the stature and
seriousness of Hillsdale College and
dealing with with issues of this sort by
the Constitution you mean the whole
Constitution and not just a couple of
the amendments to the Constitution that
were passed afterwards there actually a
couple of issues lurking in that let's
begin with the body of the Constitution
the document whose ratification that we
are marking that you were marking with
the celebration it did not as you know
include a bill of rights at the time
that was ratified and I'll get to that
in a bit but i think that the liberties
we value are really the result not so
much of their enumeration in the Bill of
Rights passed in ten amendments later on
but rather of such prosaic features of
the Constitution as a bicameral
legislature and the separation of powers
between and among the three branches of
government in between the federal
government and the states now I
recognize that when people get together
to celebrate the Constitution or to have
heated arguments about it or to
demonstrate and carry placards in favor
of adhering to it the provisions that I
mentioned they're generally not
they have in mind but they have in mind
is is right now that seems odd because
there were an are in fact other
constitutions in the world that
guarantee far more in the way of rights
than what set forth in the first ten
amendments to our own constitution the
constitution of what we now delicately
refer to as the former Soviet Union
purported to guarantee far more rights
and not only political rights of all
sorts but also the right to shelter and
sustenance into health care the whole
cornucopia of Rights and the
Constitution of the European Union
purports to guarantee all manner of
rights to those who were fortunate
enough to live in the EU I hadn't
intended that as a lifelong butter
but it is isn't it the trouble is that
neither of those Constitution's words
worth the paper it's written on because
the soviet constitution guaranteed also
the supremacy of the communist party and
failed to include the separation and
dispersion of power that characterizes
our own constitution and omission of
course which made all its other
high-sounding provisions completely
irrelevant and so far as the EU
constitutions concern it to guarantees
all manner of rights and provides for
their enforcement by the European Court
of Human Rights in Strasbourg that Court
hears such monumental cases as a claim
by someone being evicted from an
apartment in Milan that his European
right to shelter is being infringed when
I was attorney general that court had a
backlog of about 300,000 cases and it
has a decision tree that looks like it
was it was designed by Rube Goldberg now
there are there are several of you who
don't know who Rube Goldberg is and I
would advise those of you who were that
young can use your computers to look him
up on Google and it'll explain to you
who he was and of course such executive
power as there is in the EU is reposed
principally in a whole army of faceless
mandarins in Brussels who write
regulations President Obama campaigned
for office substantially on the claim
that his predecessor had shredded the
Constitution now of course by the
Constitution he didn't mean the document
whose ratification we marked today he
meant I think some of the amendments in
fact he could not have meant the
document itself because article 2 of the
document begins with the very simple
declaration that quote the executive
power shall be vested in a president of
the United States of America notice it
doesn't say some of the executive power
or most of the executive power or even
all but a teeny weeny bit of the
executive power it says the executive
power
in other words all of it this is
particularly interesting and noteworthy
when you stop and consider that the
legislative powers are enumerated what's
given to Congress is as the Constitution
says all legislative powers herein
granted oh I understand that there's a
Necessary and Proper Clause later on but
it's what's necessary and proper to
carry into Constitution the powers that
are set forth earlier in the list in
other words the founders understood
based in part on their unfortunate
experience under the Articles of
Confederation that when no one was in
charge the branch of government most
likely to be in need of the ability to
act quickly and decisively is the
executive and the branch most likely to
overreach unless the subject that could
deal with were specifically laid out was
the legislature so President Obama ran
for office when he ran for office i
should say he could not have meant that
his predecessor shredded the document
whose adoption that we're here to
commemorate because the real criticism
he was leveling and so far as it relates
to the actual constitution seems to be
that his predecessor took it too
seriously well all of that ended on
january twentieth of 2009 or did it we
had a series of executive orders aimed
mainly at undoing the policies that had
been put in place that were within the
control of the executive before that so
we had an order directing that
Guantanamo be closed within a year as
you will recall we celebrated the second
anniversary of that order in January of
2011 and I think we can all agree that
wherever that celebration was held it
was a whole lot quieter than the one
that we're holding today even though the
principal planner of the September 11
2001 @
acts Khalid Sheikh Mohammed had
announced that he was ready to plead
guilty before a military tribunal at
Guantanamo and even though he was in the
custody of the Department of Defense it
was the Justice Department that
announced in November of 2009 that his
military commission was cancelled and
instead he would be brought to the
mainland United States to stand trial in
my old court the Southern District of
New York of course that worked out too
indeed Congress passed the statute
relying on its constitutionally
enumerated powers of the purse directing
that no federal funds be used to bring
any detainee at Guantanamo to the United
States with the result that the military
commission trial for KSM and the other
detainees charged in connection with the
September 11 attacks is back on however
the processes had to start again from
scratch so here a few days after we
commemorated another anniversary a very
somber one and several years after we
actually took custody of Khalid Sheikh
Mohammed ramzi bin al-shibh and the
other defendants who were to be tried
with them there is still no date set for
the commencement of that proceeding and
paradoxically after Congress passed that
legislation the administration
complained that way that it was an
interference with the prerogative of the
executive to choose the forum for the
presentation of charges late conversion
we had another executive order in
January of 2009 suspending the CIA
interrogation program as an affront
among other things to the Constitution
indeed the mantra at the time was that
these executives orders in the large
were meant to restore standards of due
process and the Constitution instead of
these allegedly disgraceful and unlawful
interrogation techniques the world
including in our adversaries we're told
that anyone acting on behalf of the
United States government whether a
highly-trained CIA operative seeking the
most sensitive security related
information or the most junior recruit
in the field interrogating someone he's
just captured is limited by the army
field manual which because it was
drafted for general use is of course
pitched to the capabilities of the most
junior recruit in the field and has in
fact been available on the internet for
years and has been used by terrorists
for years as a training manual for
resisting interrogation a brief word
about that abandoned CIA program which
involved in what is probably the most
disastrous marketing since New Coke
something something called enhanced
interrogation techniques which were
actually not only harsh and coercive
which is what they should have been
called but also completely lawful people
other than those who debriefed the
detainees were schooled in those
techniques and when detainees subjected
to them who necessarily self-selected as
a group because they were both
knowledgeable of al-qaeda and resistant
to lesser techniques when those
detainees agreed to be compliant other
nature other agents knowledgeable in the
background of al-qaeda resumed the
interrogation we learned a great deal
for the CIA program in fact you can
focus on only three of the detainees Abu
Zubaydah Khalid Sheikh Mohammed and the
man named al rahim amar shiri
who are the only three who were
subjected to the most famous of these
techniques which is waterboarding and
see a huge trove of valuable information
with respect to waterboarding by the way
I should given the fact that only three
detainees was subjected to it and the
number of journalists who have written
that they were subjected to it and
claimed that it was torture it would
appear that more journalists have been
waterboarded than terrorists not that
that's a bad thing some of what we
learned from Abu Zubaydah according to
George Tenet and General Michael Hayden
both of whom were sequentially directors
of the CIA is information that led to
the arrest of ramzi bin al-shibh who was
a link to the higher-ups for 911 and was
planning an era an airplane attack on
canary wharf and Heathrow Airport in
England the arrest of Jose Padilla known
for probably best known for a fanciful
plot to construct a dirty bomb but who
actually planned to acquire apartments
in apartment buildings fill them with
gas seal them up and detonate them with
a cell phone and was convicted of that
we also learned that al Qaeda recruits
and this was a valuable piece of
information from Abu Zubaydah that al
Qaeda recruits were trained to resist to
the limit but that doctrinally and
religiously it was then okay for them to
talk once they had served their
obligation by reaching the limit of
their physical ability and that valuable
lesson was applied to college Sheikh
Mohammed who when he reached his limit
became virtually a tutor not only did he
disclosed general information on how al
Qaeda moved money in people but also
specific information that helped disrupt
other plots including one involving
airplanes this one directed at the
library tower in Los Angeles that was to
be carried out by a South Asian group
headed by a man named Tom Bali was also
arrested based on his information other
information received from chaos
resulted in the capture of people
involved in a plan to develop a
biological weapons capability in the
United States and on and on and Abdul
Rahim on ma cherie the third person who
was waterboarded he was the mastermind
of the attack on the coal I'm was
providing sale information until after
these techniques were applied at which
point his information became both
current and useful not only is this
interrogation program been abandoned but
when people apprehended in connection
with terrorist plots directed at this
country and there have been more than 20
since nine eleven more than a dozen of
them aimed at my hometown New York alone
when people have been apprehended in
connection with those plants even though
their principal value once they're in
custody is as sources of intelligence
they've almost uniformly been told print
turned over immediately to law
enforcement authorities warn of their
Miranda rights and treated as routine
criminal suspects what would be what did
we lose in the process what we lost when
the questioning of a man named omar
abdul mutalib who was the recall he was
the bomber apprehended or the would-be
bomber apprehended over detroit and on
christmas day of 2009 when that plot was
interrupted what we lost was information
about who had built his bomb information
if it had been followed up promptly
might well have erased that bomb builder
when bombs started showing up in
packages in DSL packages and packages on
other package by other package carriers
United Parcel and so forth originating
in Yemen it appeared that the person who
built Abdulmutallab bomb was still at
large those bombs were the same sort
that other mahtab tried to detonate and
appear to be the work of the same bomb
maker lest anyone think that this bomb
maker has never had a success or at
least an even near a success than he had
without the mutalib you should be aware
that he is believed to be the same
person who sent his own brother with a
bomb on his person to meet as a penitent
with Prince Mohammed bin Nayef who was
largely responsible for running Saudi
Arabia's
terrorism activities that bomb which was
concealed in the rectum of the person
who carried it did go off but it only
injured bin Nayef rather than killed him
and yet as I indicated before Guantanamo
remains open and despite concern for
what were referred to during the
campaign as constitutional standards by
which was meant i think standards
allegedly applicable based on amendments
to the constitution the administration
has acknowledged that one of its options
is indefinite detention of anyone deemed
too dangerous to release but as to whom
there is not enough evidence of war
crimes to bring a charge before a
military commission now although the
facility remains open it's also true
that the president remains as committed
as ever to closing it for starters no
new detainees are being brought to
guantanamo so we learned a month or two
ago that a man named warsaw me was
apprehended and was thought to be in
possession of valuable intelligence he
was placed aboard a naval vessel
debriefed for two months after which he
was advised of his miranda rights and
brought to trial and brought to the
United States for trial he was not
brought to Guantanamo because Congress
has directed that no funds can be used
to bring anyone from Guantanamo to the
United States and the administration
doesn't want to try and perform a
military commission because it disdains
military commissions notwithstanding
that they've been used before in our
history from the Revolutionary War
through and including World War two and
are provided for specifically in a
statute passed by Congress called as he
would expect the military commissions
act and of course the administration
remains as committed as ever to figuring
out a way of releasing those detained
there despite a growing body of evidence
that alumni of wanton mo when they get
out return to the battlefield one
relatively recent example is an
interview with a man named sheikh abu
sufian oh Allah is the deputy commander
of al Qaeda and the Arabian Peninsula
of the folks based in Yemen published in
the october two thousand ten issue of
that organizations english-language
magazine called inspire now for those of
you who don't have a subscription to
inspire i should tell you that you can
get a copy of the interview through a
site called the Middle East Media
Research Institute or Emmy MRI which is
a wonderful service that really deserves
your attention and support and you can
get their reports online for nothing in
this interview abu sufian who was
released from guantanamo and turned over
to the salaries for participation in
their vaunted re-education program
managed to make his way to yemen resume
is jihadi activity in this interview he
urges muslims to Emma day emulate Nidal
Hasan the fort hood shooter and abdul
mutalib the Detroit the would-be Detroit
airplane bomber this is of course by no
means the first alumnus of Guantanamo to
return to the battlefield back in March
2010 the supreme leader of the Afghan
Taliban announced that he was promoting
a man named mullah Abdul kayum Zakir to
replace a top deputy who had been
captured by US forces zakir had also
been in detention in guantanamo and
released to the Afghans in fact at least
twenty percent of those released from
Guantanamo have returned to the
battlefield and of course those are only
the ones we know about because they've
been recaptured or killed how many are
still in the fight is really anyone's
guess now a few words about Guantanamo
itself it's a military facility not a
CIA facility I visited it in February of
2008 is a state-of-the-art facility it
compares favorably with medium security
facilities forget maximum security but
medium security facilities that I had
the occasion to visit when I was
district judge in New York medium
security facilities in the federal
system i saw when i visited there most
of the high-value detainees on
closed-circuit television
which is the way they were monitored
other than Khalid Sheikh Mohammed who
was out of his cell speaking with a
visiting delegation from the
International Committee of the Red Cross
presumably to tell them of all the
horrors to which he had been exposed but
I did manage to visit his cell and
discovered that adjoining it was an
exercise room that featured an
elliptical machine that was the same
make and model as the one that I used at
the gym in the landsberg apartments
where I lived when I was Attorney
General the courtroom at Guantanamo is
enormously expensive it can handle
high-security detainees and secure
information direct from the mainland by
a computer the medical care that's given
to detainees there is better than the
care that's given to their captors the
library includes many Islamic and other
titles as well as DVDs as it happens the
most popular right and when I was there
with DVDs of a program called Walker
Texas Ranger that's not to say that
there isn't violence at Guantanamo
there's plenty of it but it's directed
by the detainees of their guards not the
other way around I saw the plastic face
shield that guards have to wear to
protect them against the cocktails of
urine and other solids and fluids that
are thrown at them when they get
anywhere near the cells I should add
that this itch to release detainees from
Guantanamo despite a profess willingness
to entertain the possibility of
indefinite detention not only is not
dictated by the constitutional or any of
its amendments it isn't dictated by the
laws of war in fact it turns out it
turns those laws on their head what it
says in essence is that if you obey all
the laws of war that humankind has
developed over the last several hundred
years in order to try to civilize combat
to the extent possible that if you carry
your arms openly wear a uniform you
follow a recognized chain of command and
you don't target civilians you can be
detained until hostilities cease but
what the administration appears to be
saying is that if you disobey all of
those laws then we've got an even better
deal for you will bring you to an
article three Courtney night
States if we can get you a lawyer the
benefit of rules designed for routine
crimes as well as a platform to express
your views and if we can't do all that
will release you which is about as
impressive a set of perverse incentives
as you could possibly come up with so
with all this to and fro as between the
two political branches of government and
the courts where do we stand well the
intelligence gathering techniques that
were adopted and followed during the
preceding administration remain not only
on the books but actively pursued and
although we've had a tax here both
attempted and accomplished we've had
nothing on the scale of September 11 and
of course thanks to a vigorous and
courageous exercise of the article 2
power of the commander in chief and the
splendid and courageous performance of
the team of Navy SEALs Osama bin Laden
is dead now I certainly would not
minimize that achievement he needed
killing badly and he and we needed that
it be done at the hands of Americans and
it was and it was done in a way that
allowed us to exploit the trove of
electronic and written intelligence that
was found in his home although one could
wish that less had been said at the time
about that trove because once it was
disclosed you can bet that every
terrorist who had contact with him or
that location made adjustments in his
circumstances and routine and of course
his death has great symbolic
significance because he had attained by
the time of his death took totemic
significance certainly at least from the
ten years after September 11 2001 but
it's impossible to gauge the
significance of his death unless and
until we recognize the simple fact that
our encounter with Osama bin Laden and
with what he stood for it and its
encounter with us did not begin on
September 11 2001 what he stood for was
Islamism and as a matter of history
Islamism insofar as it holds this
country in a kind of weird combination
of awe and contempt has been incubating
for about as long as we've known about
the other two isms that we successfully
conquered in the last century fascism
and communism
as a movement distinct from the religion
of Islam itself Islamism traces back to
Egypt in the 1920s when the loosely
organized muslim brotherhood was
established by a man in hassan al-banna
a primary school teacher albana founded
the Muslim Brotherhood as a reaction to
the modern modernizing influence a kemal
ataturk who had dismantled the shell of
what was left of the Muslim caliphate in
Turkey had banned fezzes and headscarves
and dragged his country by the lapels
and it had to be lapels because nobody
was allowed to wear rose into the 20th
century al banas principal disciple was
also an educator a bureaucrat of the
Education Department of the Egyptian
government named Syed kutub who caused
enough trouble in Egypt to get himself a
warder to traveling fellowship in 1948
which was the year that al banna was
killed in violence generated by the
Muslim Brotherhood that fellowship was
intended to have the benign effect of
getting a man of the country and it did
of course have that effect but
regrettably for us he chose to travel to
the United States in a particular to
greeley colorado now I think that would
probably be hard to imagine a more
inoffensive place than World War 2 then
post World War to greeley colorado but
for a man line likes i could have it was
Sodom and Gomorrah he hated everything
he saw American haircuts enthusiasm for
sports jazz what he called the animal
like mixing of the sexes even in church
his conclusion was that Americans were
in his words numb to faith in our faith
and religion and faith in spiritual
values all together and he said that
Muslims must regard as he put it the
white man with a European or American as
our first enemy he said Muslims must
make this the cornerstone of our foreign
policy and national education well could
have went back to Egypt quit the civil
service joined a house on Alabama's
Muslim Brotherhood Coulomb could have
been a Muslim Brotherhood continued to
agitate for return to fundamentalism in
Islam they welcomed NASA's coup against
the corrupt monarchy in 1952 but then
became disillusioned when
with nasir when he not only failed
instance that Sharia Lloyd in even ban
alcohol could have opposed Nasir was
arrested and tortured however he
continued to write and to agitate
against Western civilization
particularly against Jews who he blamed
for atheistic materialism and said were
to be considered the worst enemies of
Muslims he was released for a time but
eventually was re-arrested convicted of
conspiracy against the government and
hanged in 1966 many members of the
Brotherhood fled to Saudi Arabia where
they found refuge and ideological
substance sustenance kuta brother was
among those who fled and he taught the
doctrine in saudi arabia among his
students were a man named Ayman
al-zawahri an Egyptian who would become
a leading al-qaeda ideologist and is now
according to reports the leader of
al-qaeda and a venn obscure young fellow
named Osama bin Laden the pampered child
of the rich one of the richest
construction families in the country and
the rest as they say is history that
history did not come to be shores as I
indicated on September 11 2001 or even
on ferry 26 1993 when a truck bomb went
off in the basement of the Royal Trade
Center killing six people wounding
hundreds causing millions of dollars in
damage in what would eventually become
known as the First World Trade Center
bombing rather it came at the latest in
the 1980s when a couple of FBI agents
spotted a group of men taking what
looked to them to be particularly
aggressive target practice at a shooting
range out in Calvert in Long Island when
they approached those men they were
accused of what we now call profiling
and backed off in november of nineteen
ninety one of those men el Sayyid Nosair
would assassinate a right-wing Israeli
politician named Mark ahana in the
ballroom of Manhattan hotel the case was
treated by the Manhattan da Robert
Morgenthau as the loan act of a lone
gunman when the 1993 World Trade Center
bombers demanded freeing nosair from
jail it became apparent that the kana
assassinate
was not the loan act of a lone gunman
and when authorities reviewed the
amateur of videotape of kahana speech
that night the night that he was killed
it was discovered that one of those 1993
bombers had been in the hole at the time
and that another was supposed to be
driving what was to be the getaway car
the man who served as the spiritual
advisor to no ser to the 1993 Trade
Center bombers and who would later issue
from jail the fatwa that authorized the
2001 attacks omar abdel-rahman the
so-called blind sheikh along with no sir
and several others were tried before me
and convicted for participating in a
conspiracy to conduct a war of urban
terror against this country that
included the Cohanim murder the first
trade center bombing and a plot to blow
up other landmarks around New York to
assassinate Hosni Mubarak when he
visited the united nations and other
acts the list of unindicted
co-conspirators in that case included
Osama bin Laden the pampered rich kid
who had studied at the knee of sight
quit tubes brother in Saudi Arabia the
government was required in that case as
it is in all criminal cases with as a
conspiracy count to serve a list of
unindicted co-conspirators on the
defense and we later found that 10 days
after that list was served it made its
way to Khartoum where bin Laden was then
in residence and so he learned not only
that we knew about him but who else we
knew about as well at the time all of
this was treated as a series of crimes
unconventional crimes maybe but merely
crimes in 1996 and again in 1998 in
Laden declare that he and his cohorts
were at war with the United States
declarations that were treated as quaint
and got very little serious attention in
1998 our embassies in Nairobi Kenya Dar
es Salaam Tanzania were almost
simultaneously bombed and again the
criminal law was invoked with the usual
mantra of bringing them to justice this
time in fact an indictment was filed in
the Southern District of New York that
named bin Laden miss and defendant
apparently he was unimpressed or at
least undeterred because in two thousand
his group al-qaeda bombed the USS Cole
and aden yemen killing 16 US sailors and
would have carried out another bombing
of another naval vessel called the USS
the sullivans but for the fact that the
barge carrying the explosives was
overloaded and sang and then of course
came September 11 2001 and to the call
bring them to justice was added the call
bring justice to them and so we were
told that we were at war which was more
than 50 years after site could have
determined that Islamists would have to
make war on us about 15 years after
Islamists had made it clear that they
were training for war with us and five
years after Osama bin Laden made it
official with a declaration of war in
fighting Islamism we are handicapped at
the strategic level in no small measure
by the refusal of many of those in
authority to acknowledge the goals of
our adversaries those goals are
essentially political and involve the
recreation of the Islamic caliphate and
the imposition of Sharia law over his
broader swath of the world as possible
this is a profoundly anti-democratic
movement at its core and regards the
very idea of man-made law as anathema
instead we try to be in offensive by
using a term that actually originated in
the administration in which I served and
we refer to a war on terror or terrorism
people who wish its equivalent a clear
discussion off into absurdity if such
people were entirely at the periphery I
suppose it wouldn't matter much but
right now I have to tell you that some
of such people are right at the core of
where there should be clarity one of
them in fact is one of the president's
assistance for national security who
actually got up in front of an audience
at the Center for Strategic Studies and
this is one of our officially designated
deep thinkers talking to other
officially designated deep thinkers and
ridicule the idea of a war on terrorism
or terror saying you can't have a war on
a means or a state of mind well that
actually called to my mind a zany
British review that ran on a Broadway
before men
you were born call Beyond the Fringe and
in particular one sketch from that
review involving a police spokesman for
Scotland Yard trying to explain to the
press why Scotland Yard had not yet
solved what was then the Great Train
Robbery of 1963 and he said that they
had had first been confused by the name
Great Train Robbery but after
investigation they had found that trains
were quite large they were nearly
impossible to conceal that they ran on
Rails and so were generally very hard to
make off with so you see he said Great
Train Robbery is a misnomer there's no
question here at all of a missing train
we we have the train it's the contents
of the train that a missing on now now
that review was a force on but John
Brennan the president's national
security expert did not consider his
remarks of the Center for Strategic
Studies to be a force this failure also
distorts the view of policymakers about
what's happening in the Middle East and
so they daydream about Democratic
movements when the reality on the ground
is more populous than democratic the
principal beneficiary of populism is
more likely to be the Muslim Brotherhood
than the local spokesman for facebook
the Credo of the Muslim Brotherhood has
six inked and it is chilling that credo
is as follows all I is our goal the
Prophet Muhammad is our leader the Quran
is our Constitution jihad is our way and
death in the way of Allah is our
promised end if the death of bin Laden
is more than simply a spasm or an
opportunity to engage in
self-congratulation if it helps provide
some insight into the nature of what it
is we're fighting into the ISM of the
current century then it will have been
significant in need but if not its
significance will be substantially
diminished the signs do not seem
promising even on September 11 2011 as
was pointed out by fouad Ajami a fellow
at the Hoover Institution in Palo Alto
and a brilliant observer of these issues
there was no discussion whatever of the
people who perpetrated the atrocity
there was only a discussion of the event
as if it were like a flood or an
earthquake he pointed in particular to
one of the 19 ziad jarrah tarrah was a
Lebanese and the most western eyes of
the hijackers indeed there was doubt
among them almost to the last minute as
to whether he would participate it
johnny has pointed out that Jarrah was
raised in Beirut and was raised in the
cosmopolitan spirit of that city he then
went to Hamburg Germany where he was
radicalized it was said of Gerada he
never missed a party in Beirut but he
never missed a prayer in Hamburg it was
in the West that he was radicalized just
as it was in the West that Nidal Hasan
the fort hood shooter was reticle was
radicalized jera wind up at the controls
of flight 93 the flight that was
supposed to hit the capital but didn't
because the passengers aboard that
flight learned what it already happened
at the World Trade Center and the
Pentagon figured out in a few short
moments what was in store for them in
their country and chose to act there's
much to be learned from those facts
starts from the last which teaches the
importance of intelligence the
passengers on flight 93 were able to act
because of what they had learned about
what was going on elsewhere intelligence
gathering must be not only our number
one priority it must be numbers one two
and three the people waging war on us
and that is what it is our part of a
movement that does not occupy any
particular place or country that we can
demolish and pronounce ourselves the
winners they live in some cases among us
and the only way we have of opposing
them successfully is to find out it in
advance what they intend to do and to
thwart it second note that you're always
recognized not in the Middle East was
radicalized I'm sorry not in the Middle
East but in the West you must be aware
of those in our society who wish to
create closed ethnic zones where muslims
may essentially run their own affairs
and outsiders enter only at their peril
this has already happened in the suburbs
of French cities in parts of England in
places you ordinarily would not expect
it to happen Malmo Sweden for example
that allows radicalisation to go on
undetected guidelines have been put in
place to allow the FBI to function for
the first time in its history as an
intelligence gathering organization and
not simply as a law enforcement agency
if the bureau partners with state and
local law enforcement notably but not
exclusively with a police department
like the one in New York which has a
robust intelligence gathering capability
of its own then the kind of insular
activity that allowed Gerada be
radicalized be broken up those
guidelines must remain in place and must
be defended doing that will take an
intelligent understanding of the part of
the Constitution that I have not spoken
about at length the part that many
people outside this room think they're
talking about when they refer to the
Constitution that part what we call the
Bill of Rights provides robust
protection to both public and private
activity that we value that is in fact
essential for the continuation of our
civic life but it does not require that
we close our eyes when there are people
plainly setting the stage for activity
that is in no way protected so the First
Amendment protects both free speech and
freedom of worship and it permits the
preaching even of violence in the name
of religion but it does not guarantee to
anyone that such speech will go
undetected or that evidence of it cannot
be presented in a court when and if it
is appropriate to charge that both the
speaker and those that whom he spoke
understood this protected speech and
took it as a call to unprotected action
even action that itself consists only of
speech such as agreement to commit a
crime which is itself the crime of
conspiracy and the Fourth Amendment
protects against unreasonable searches
and seizures it contains a separate one
clause providing that warrants may issue
only on a finding of probable cause that
does not mean that a search conducted
for intelligence purposes requires a
warrant only that it be reasonable the
fifth and sixth amendments guarantee due
process and counsel to those accused of
crimes and the right to confront
witnesses but their application is
limited to criminal trials which is to
say two trials occurring
article 3 courts how much processes do
and what kind of evidence may be
received and under what circumstances in
other tribunals convened for special
purposes such as military commissions is
an entirely different story with the
adoption of the Constitution the part we
mark with today's proceedings when that
was being debated there were many
including Patrick Henry and other
luminaries who opposed the Constitution
because it did not include within the
very body of it a bill of rights but if
you included within the very body of the
document that constituted the government
the rights of citizens against that
government god-given why it's no less
the message could be taken essentially
as an invitation for everybody to simply
go his or her own way so I would submit
to you that a hidden message lurking as
it were in the structure of the
Constitution is that those acting
lawfully under it deserve at least the
benefit of the doubt when they act to
protect the common good now that's not
meant to be a statement or a suggestion
of a jurisprudential standard a standard
of law but it is meant and I do mean it
emphatically as a Prudential standard of
standard of civics and public discourse
that I think will help keep intact the
system that we and those outside this
room depend on to preserve the nation
that another lawyer speaking at another
time of trouble called the last best
hope of Earth words that I submit to you
are actually more true today and when
Abraham Lincoln first spoke I thank you
very much for inviting
now I'm told that there was to be a Q&A
period I don't know whether I've spoken
over my time to the point where we can't
have that or not I'm perfectly willing
to do it there are microphones available
to those who have questions and there's
gentlemen with his hand raised well the
solution is a not to not to not to
release them and be i guess the solution
is the one suggested in a cable i heard
of I didn't see it but I heard of it
when I was attorney general from
somebody in the field said we captured
this guy once before we've just killed
him could you please not send us any
more
that's actually a topic of of some
debate has no non-citizens who are not
detained in this country are supposed to
have no habeas rights that changed with
the gone with the case decided in from
Guantanamo in which essentially the
supreme court said that detainees at
Guantanamo regardless of their
nationality are entitled to habeas like
rights and it then told then invited the
federal courts to improvise now I don't
know how many article three judges a
full article three judges there are in
the room and I am second only to several
article three judges in my admiration
for the federal judiciary but I will
tell you that when you invite federal
judges to improvise many of them will
accept the invitation with open arms and
being human beings they won't always
improvise the same way and so what we
found in the District of Columbia is
that people with like cases are getting
unlike results
and the DC Circuit is having to
straighten it all out we can't and
shouldn't have to continue that so far
as though the availability of a pious
corpus to u.s. citizens regardless it
was a case called ex parte quirin
decided back in the 1940s when two
groups of Germans landed off Long Island
in north Florida and tried to infiltrate
this country to conduct sabotage one of
them claimed to be a US citizen they
were permitted to file Rittz challenging
the jurisdiction of the military
commission before which they were tried
and they were tried in a military
commission in Washington notwithstanding
that the courts were open and as to the
one claiming to be a US citizen the
Supreme Court said that was a material
that once somebody had cast in his lot
with people who were at war with the
United States he would be treated as
somebody at war with the United States
hi I have a question about about judges
themselves it seems to me that we have
have had so many rulings ever since the
original war on terror started that just
go against what the Constitution meant
and I am wondering is it possible how
hard is it to overturn for instance the
habeas corpus rule that you just
mentioned well the ruling I mentioned in
the in the boumediene case was decided
by the Supreme Court the United States
so that's kind of hard to overturn the
rulings of individual district judges
can be overturned by courts of Appeal
the one advantage we have in the fact
that some of these cases are arising at
Guantanamo is that these folks aren't
here once people come to the United
States be vey aliens be a citizens they
have certain rights that engage as soon
as they had these shores and those
include access to federal courts to file
all manner of habeas corpus suits suits
challenging conditions of conviction and
so forth which is why Congress has been
so resistant to bring people over from
Guantanamo so far we've been successful
with that but it's very much a holding
action as to ask the federal judges the
business doesn't attract shrinking
violets this next question comes from
our online audience Ted asks how does
the executive branch balance its power
as commander-in-chief with congressional
authority through funding of the Armed
Forces is this tension healthy for
justice and self-government um the
executive I mean there has always been
tension between the executive and the
legislature that the they move they rub
against each other like tectonic plates
and that's not abnormal and it's not
necessarily unhealthy Congress showed
recently what happens when the executive
has a power that Congress believe that's
about to misuse in a gross sort of way
and that is that it is corrected by the
rather crude invocation of the power of
the purse to cut off funds paradoxically
one of the effects of the congressional
bill that bars the bringing of anybody
from Montana mow is that it means that
at least this administration won't take
anybody to Guantanamo because Congress
found that they couldn't be trusted with
the authority to distinguish between
those who could be brought to the United
States for trial and those equipment so
it's the system we have it functions I
think by and large well and i would i
would not experiment with it in favor of
another system my question is
you identified Islam as the enemy or the
ISM of today I'm wondering if you have
any qualifiers for that or if it's your
view that all of Islam no no I tried to
be careful and if I didn't I really
should be sternly reviewed in
distinguishing between Islam and
Islamism those are two very different
things I'm not a theologian there are
reformed elements within Islam there are
people who are really interested in
moderate Islam the trouble is that
doctrinally it is very hard to find
support for those people and it is
certainly hard when our administration
when it conducts outreach conducts
outreach to the loudest voices in the
Islamic community who turn out to be
people who advocate a much more militant
form of religion and a much more
ambitious on political agenda my own
view is we're going to be conducting
outreach to people of reasonable view
not to act organizations like care and
is
yes how exactly would would you clearly
define the criteria for deciding whether
somebody should be treated as a
terrorist and outside the normal process
of law how would you define that
criteria how would you give instructions
to people who would actually have to
carry that out in the field part of it
involves circumstances of capture part
of it involves where they acted people
captured on the battlefield abroad who
are planning or any place overseas we're
planning terrorist acts by and large are
not captured under circumstances that
permit those or capture them to do
things like comply with the federal
rules of evidence in gathering evidence
that permit them to get a person a
lawyer and give them meaningful Miranda
warnings and so forth those cases are
very unsuitable for prosecution in
article 3 courts there are cases that
are suitable for prosecution in article
3 courts and those can be prosecuted
when evidence can be gathered under
circumstances that allows compliance
with the federal rules of evidence but
you shouldn't have to bring a soldier
over from Afghanistan in order to
testify that the circumstances of
capture of a terrorist nor should you
require that they do CSI kandahar every
time they capture somebody who might
conceivably be charged I think people
captured in the United States should be
seen principally upon their capture as
people to be exploited for intelligence
value and we can worry about trying them
in civilian courts if possible on when
as an if their intelligence value was
exploited the when when abu talib was
captured he committed his crime if you
recall in front of a couple hundred
passengers on an airplane the only thing
that would have been lost by simply
holding him and interrogating him would
have been his confession given the fact
that he committed his
I'm in front of a couple hundred
witnesses I don't know that we really
needed his confession some intelligent
focus on that I think would be
appropriate gather intelligence first
and worry about intelligence first worry
about trials later on general this
morning um there was discussion about
the federal overreach of what should be
state jurisdiction in making an
enforcing laws and I know we all have
Americans have seen this become
increasingly imposed in our personal
lives you someone mentioned light bulbs
but I'm more concerned about black
blanket vaccine programs that are
supposed to be for the common good but
federal laws that impro chon everything
in our lives that take no respect to the
individual vaccines is one thing on the
on one hand we're compelled to inject
into the bloodstream of children eye on
things that may or may not be in their
best interest but on the other hand it's
illegal to buy fresh pressed apple cider
in the state of Virginia I mean these
are federal laws and it's talk about
overreach where it used to be something
that the states could decide and then
you mentioned sir the Fourth Amendment
protection against unreasonable searches
maybe there's a lot of people in this
room that same was saw the same video
that I saw we're at an airport the TSA
was doing there unreasonable searches on
the body of a three-year-old child who
was apparently the only person in the
airport that had any common sense she
was screaming take your hands off of me
and um it's gotten to the point where I
feel like we're being groomed for
something I mean we're we're accepting
you can't buy Jews you have to be
vaccinated you have to be searched at an
airport what comes next is next thing is
it going to be the microchip that
everybody feels like okay well now in
order to be safe everyone has to be
microchipped my question to you sir is I
think the TSA is behaving
unconstitutionally and I've refused to
fly since the day these things were
implemented because I know when I get to
the airport i'm down to get arrested
because i'll refuse both to be noob done
to be felt up so at what point do we
finally address this constitutional
issue and is anything about being done
about it well um
youth you've touched you touched on a
variety of issues
and of course the last thing in the
world I want to do is stand up here and
defend TSA I think that if we had a
program that permeated the recruitment
of people who know what they're doing we
could screen passengers as regrettably
we have to in ways that don't involve
what TSA does
okay um I suppose I would reverse the
roles here for a moment and ask you
whether you would want the people who do
the searches at TSA to be the focus
administering the program you just
described my answer to that question is
no okay that said I think we need to
screen people before they get on
airplanes that was proved on September
11 and I've had my own I've had my own
experiences with with with screening
when I was a federal judge I traveled
with a security detail of marshals who
carried guns when I traveled on
commercial airlines more than once I was
picked out for the intensive screening
and so might the marshals who are with
me on the security detail stood by
patiently with their guns while I was
screened for a nail clipper it's a
paradox in some ways it's a farce but it
is pretty much only an inconvenience
this will be our final question it seems
to me that President Obama has a
solution to the problem of Carrick at
capturing people when they went in to
get Osama bin Laden they were obviously
told to kill him because they could have
captured him and is that all I think I
think in fairness to them I think they
were probably told that if he
unambiguously well offer to surrender
then accept a surrender I somehow doubt
that he unambiguously offered does a
little attitude there but the other
thing is you just send our UAV after
them and we don't have any capture
problem yeah neither do we get any
intelligence there in the problem and I
find it paradoxical that people who
object on You Man
tarian grounds to detaining people think
absolutely nothing of dropping a UAV on
them and ending their lives in the lives
of anybody around them not a whole lot
of due process involved in that is there